you're three days away from a dream that
you've had for a long time
biggest gig biggest gig in the game
right how do you prepare to make this a
spectacle
you know the spectacle is the music the
way that we speak is through the music
and the way that we emot-- and perform
is through the music so yeah I think
that this has been you know the curation
I guess of the show and putting it
together in that whole process figuring
out what we're gonna do how we're gonna
do it that is all being centered around
the music this performance there has
been controversy around you guys playing
this performance and desert whoa just a
little what would into your decision to
play the Super Bowl halftime show you
know I think that when you look back on
every single Super Bowl halftime show
mm-hmm
people just can't it's it's this like
insatiable urge to to hate a little bit
I'm not in the right profession if I
can't handle a little bit of controversy
it's what it is we expected it you'd
like to move on from it and like I said
earlier speak through amuse the music
did you talk to anybody before you made
the decision maybe III I did I spoke to
many people but most importantly though
when I silenced all the noise listen to
myself
and made my decision based upon how I
felt why'd you guys cancel this press
conference the NFL canceled the press
conference you'll have to speak what's
that has this changed the way you go
about this performance
I could say yes and no because honestly
I think that being in a band and being
an artist in publicly appearing and
performing you have to take into account
all of the things are surrounding you
and in that case it's no different than
any other concert so no you know I think
that we're we put together a show based
upon the things that we had collected
over the last twenty years and most
recently I think we just wanted to make
sure that we were able to speak once
again through the music mm-hmm and so
yes absolutely we once we processed all
of these things and I say look it took a
lot of kind of looking inward it took a
lot of introspection and I thought to
myself what's my greatest tool you know
what's what's the thing that I can use
to express myself and what's the best
way for the band they express themselves
in how are we gonna do it this year
what do we owe ourselves what do we owe
the people and that's what we did and
I'm beyond proud of the finished product
and literally never I've never been more
excited in my entire life to present
this to the people because I believe
that it's truly a reflection of all of
us you know you're not someone who would
take this decision lightly and looking
at know the past people you've
collaborated I'm assuming that when you
say you looked inside you looked inside
hard I did I did I did absolutely 100% I
will never sit here and deny that I
think that it's a not to have not done
that would have been deeply
irresponsible so I did no one thought
about it more than I did no one put more
thought and love it for this now you
have Travis Scott one of the young bucks
young man young Travis Scott he's being
incredible to him and he's he's he's
great this is a moment for him
and we love what he does obviously we
love what he represents because we love
having there be a presence that there
this is the the show that's gonna have
the biggest hip hop presence that there
has ever been on the show I mean I can't
look back and find that to have been the
case before so he's it he's the man
right now and he comes in hot